[Music]
Oh Maddy you'll always be one of the
best dance mom stars of all time you're
making waves all around the world and
we're so happy for you but there's just
something we need to know and it's
everything to do with your old friends
from the ALDC we know you hate talking
about Dance Moms but why did you have to
cut all your friends out of your life
did they do something or were you just
ready to move on what we thought were
lifelong friendships quickly fizzles out
once the stars of Dance Moms left the
show some of them make it a point to
stay in touch well others leave each
other on read keep watching to find out
which star is still good friends with
almost everyone from the ALDC she is
losing her right-hand man Melissa and
her number one student Maddie
Jojo see wha and Maddie Ziegler Jojo and
Maddie are very different people but
that never stopped them from getting
along they used to be good friends
before they both left the Dance Moms
cast in season six but evidently their
bond wasn't meant to last it's been
years since Maddie and Jojo made time
for each other
however Maddie didn't hesitate to defend
Jojo during a meet-and-greet in
Australia back in 2015
Maddie posted a picture of Jojo and
herself in the summer of 2016 which is
the last time Jojo has appeared on
Maddie's Instagram so what changed well
for starters
Jojo visited Abby Lee Miller in the
hospital and stood by her throughout the
scandal and well Maddie has very
different views when it comes to her
former dance coach in 2019 Jojo threw a
huge sweet 16 birthday party and invited
Abby and many of the girls from the ALDC
however Maddie was nowhere to be found
Jojo Cu ah
and Mackenzie Ziegler Mackenzie is only
one year younger than Jojo and they've
shared a stage many times before these
dancers bumped heads at times but they
quickly became good friends
but once the Ziggler's left Dance Moms
things started to change and both Maddie
and Mackenzie seemed to have cut ties
with Jojo just like her big sister
Mackenzie didn't attend Jojo sweet 16
celebration and she hasn't posted any
pictures with her for almost two years
but we can't exactly blame her because
it's possible that Jojo through some
serious shade Kenzie's way Jojo has
commented on being grossed out by some
of her friends Instagram pages and some
fans think she was pointing to Kenzie's
page after all Kenzie is younger than
Jojo but dresses much older than her who
do you think Jojo was referring to sound
off in the comments
Bryn rum fellow and Cameron bridges
Cameron bridges became an official
member of the ALDC during season seven
of Dance Moms and she quickly became
friends with Brynn rum fellow who joined
the cast in season six but their
friendship eventually turned sour due to
Brynn liking a comment on Instagram that
made fun of the Elise Cameron and the
girls moms retaliated online making a
bad situation worse
Cameron countered by calling Brynn fake
but according to Cameron she didn't
actually say that she explained that the
Dance Moms executives played around with
the footage making her look bad in the
process
either way the incident caused a rift
between Cameron and Brynn and the rest
is pretty much history kendall vertes
and Cameron Bridges Kendall and Cameron
were never the best of friends but at
one point they got along just fine but
as season seven came to a close Kendall
and Cameron started bumping heads
Cameron Chloe Kalani Kendall and Nia
formed the irreplaceable but in 2017 the
group went on tour but didn't invite
Cameron to come along what was already a
shaky friendship took a turn for the
worst and Kendall and Cameron never
patched things up Maddie Ziegler and
Chloe Lucas yeah Maddie and Chloe were
the best of friends for as long as we
can remember
despite being pegged against each other
during their entire time on Dance Moms
the girls always found a way to support
each other and be kind to one another
everyone loved their friendship but Abby
Lee Miller's actions may have caused
some resentment between the two dancers
Chloe used to be really good friends but
maybe they're not friends anymore
both Maddie and Chloe have expressed how
much love and admiration they have for
each other however they don't have a
connection anymore
despite wishing each other the best they
don't hang out like the use to the
Ziegler sisters and Abby Lee Miller it's
no secret that the Ziegler sisters don't
want anything to do with their former
dance coach Abby Lee Miller for years
Abby favoured Maddie and Mackenzie over
the rest of her students which made
things super awkward after leaving the
show the Ziegler sisters cut all ties
with Abby and refused to visit her in
the hospital comment on her jail
sentence or include her in their
autobiographies shade has been thrown
back and forth between them ever since
and it's not about to stop anytime soon
Chloe Lucas Jack and Abby Lee Miller
despite making a guest appearance in
season 7 after leaving the show in tears
in season 4 Chloe and Abby never
reconciled their relationship Abby
constantly put Chloe down and labeled
her as number 2 but the cherry on top
was when she told Christi to go fix her
daughter's eye this severely impacted
Khloe's self-confidence and resulted in
the Lucchese act leaving the show and
Xing Abby out of their lives Dance Moms
is a dramatic show that can bring the
worst out of people but if there's one
person who's managed to stay true to
herself throughout the series its Nia Co
she keeps in contact with the girls and
visits them when she can who is your
favorite Dance Moms star tell us in the
comments and that's a wrap
thanks for watching the things hit that
subscribe button and don't forget to
give this video a big thumbs up see you
later
[Music]